sans capote cheval cédric 6h et gris ci
et c'est au point virgule mesdames
messieurs hockey quel effet ça fait bien
c'est bizarre comme un an peuvent pas
tant que ça je les regarde jouer parce
qu ils sont si mignons parce qu'il
resterait que les indications que
j'aurais donné en même temps il propose
des choses elle
qu'est-ce qui fera comme qualités pour
bien jouer palmade est très chouette
être l élégant élégant
non mais c'est déjà faux pas vous faire
rire avec soi même pas de soi c'est pas
la peine de sortir tous les soirs de non
non non je ne pense pas maurice le
déjoue les deux noms d'être bisexuelle
non pas là et c'est important de le dire
commencez la nuit en ce moment pierre
non j'ai fait une soirée chez moi et je
te jure je veux et j'étais tellement
bourré échouer la soirée chiante jeudi
est revenu cette soirée je me cache moi
et j'ai appelé un taxi pour rentrer chez
moi j'avais j'avais bien excuser car un
état qui arrive je descends je monte
comme je peux dans le taxi et je lui
donne l'adresse et il me reconnaît il
mais on y est là là là je rencontre ce
que je faisais l'orgueil reprend le
dessus et je fais mais je sais je le
vois faire des blagues
ah ouais
ouais bien il ya quelqu'un qu'on voit
pas trop la nuit en ce moment c'est
muriel robin a été tourné non j'imagine
au secours elle a fini avec brio loin le
grand rex et l'entente n'est là je crois
qu'elle se repose mais elle va bientôt
partir en tournée comment ça va avec
elle très bien très bien vous souvenez
quand on avait fait le truc de maliens
poires et là c'est un des plus beaux
canaux qu'en effet en télé c'est c'est
humain perd vite de faire en sorte qu'on
se rappelle et qu'on oublie ça mayer et
poires et je suis alors on va en voir un
petit bout c'est une émission qu'on ait
préparé avec catherine barma et pierre
palmade consacré à jacqueline maillan et
jean poiret et on va en voir juste un
petit bout le final dit magnéto serge
magnéto serre